hey youtubers is Charlie so this week we
continue our rewatch of Avatar The Last
Airbender with episode 3 the southern
air temple one of my favorite early
avatar episodes just because we get to
see scary
Aang and Agni Kai so here we go if
you're brand new here we're rewatching
all the last airbender episodes and I'm
just doing a weekly avatar giveaway
details at the end of the video careful
for spoilers I know it's silly to say
that but let's start with top five
moments number five team aang family car
trip so now that they've gotten away
from Zuko safely in the Fire Nation
soldiers aang has gone full-blown
Disneyland crazy it's like Sokka is the
sleepy dad who promised he'd take little
kid Aang to Disneyland on his one
weekend off from his ice fishing job all
he cares about is getting another hours
sleep but Aang just starts poking the
hell out of him
in his sleeping bag then Katara's like
the mom trying to calm him down
maybe Disneyland won't be as awesome as
you remembered it just try not to drink
too much Red Bull and Mountain Dew
before we get there this plays out like
almost every single family car trip I
ever went on except I have a little
brother and a little sister
so my scenario was more like after Toph
and Zuko showed up and it got a little
more crowded on top of Appa and just to
be clear no I never drank Mountain Dew
in redbull as a child
that's disgusting number four meet
commander Zhao I'd say of all the last
airbender villains jo is one of my
favorites him showing up make Zuko
starts seeming more sympathetic you know
not that it's super clear from their
first interaction here
Zuko is still in Super bro mode but Jo
trying to shut him down immediately does
make you forget the Zuko almost just
destroyed an entire village of innocent
people yeah he almost went super dark it
also kind of helps that they have
imagery of all these other Fire Nation
ships in the background like if you
thought Zuko was bad just you wait
there's that really familiar phrase out
of the pot and into the frying pan it's
pretty apt given the Fire Nation
overtones and the Agni Kai and the fact
the Zuko almost does get cooked in that
fight most of you already know that
jason isaacs is the voice actor Brian
Mike said that jazz character
specifically was based on Jason's
villain character from the patriot
that's an old Mel Gibson movie during
that he plays a British imperialist
character just reaving and raping his
way across colonial America most of you
probably know him way better as lucius
malfoy from harry potter so usually when
I talk about gel and jason isaacs i
talked about harry potter stuff his
character in the patriot was way
worse than lucius malfoy but that movie
is one of the longest movies ever its
interminable so unless you want to
torture yourself
just stick with Lucius Malfoy and the
Harry Potter films so the Josue Koh
stuff provides all the dramatic tension
at least until egg finds out that all
his friends are dead for the most part
the episode bounces back between the
really fun and really dramatic stuff
which is one of the reasons why I really
liked last airbender episodes they just
they do a really good job of being both
funny and really dramatic at the same
time like going back and forth between
one and the other seamlessly I think the
last season of Korra was way heavier on
drama so I always walked away from those
episodes feeling really emotionally
drained so if you want to feel better
about yourself
I think last airbender is a better tea
to drink number three Chou explains the
fire nation's grand plan there's so much
going on in this Zuko Zhao storyline but
it also serves as this giant info dump
on the future of the fire nations plans
and it shines a light on Zuko's father
Fire Lord Ozai it's a good reminder that
no matter how bad Jaa seems he's just
following the orders of the Fire Lord
order the orders as he interprets them
you get a lot of that with minions
they're given specific orders but then
they go off-book and that's usually
where things go bad the big reminder
here I think is that map does this not
remind you of kuvira staring at the map
during korra last year Brian and Mike
have always done a really good job of
invoking last airbender imagery and
Korra episodes so now that we're
rewatching the old stuff try to pick out
familiar Korra scenes that's like one of
the biggest things I do whenever i
rewatch big anthology series it's really
fun usually the first time when you
watch something you're more focused on
the plot and like what's going on with
the characters on the surface level so
you miss like little background visual
details number two at the southern air
temple so they finally arrive and ink
takes them on the on the Grand Tour the
air ballcourt
nice reminder for a meelo playing with
the new airbenders and Korra book 3 and
how they turned that whole back mountain
slope into the crazy obstacle course I
still want to go I want a vacation I
wanna have a vacation at the southern
air temple even though now it's probably
still being rebuilt just the idea the
airbenders which on the surface seemed
like such a Zen group of people have a
game they would play is so much fun like
Aang is a child of course he's gonna be
playing games all the time sometimes you
look at the adult characters and forget
that maybe that's why the core
characters spent
time doing fun stuff just because
they're all in their early 20s by the
time the series ended and all that egg
timers were way way younger I'd say you
know of the Southern Air temple
locations the Hall of Avatar statue is
probably my favorite place opening the
door here so much fun it actually kind
of reminds me of Harry Potter with the
Chamber of Secrets just using magic to
open doors I guess you could also
consider it like opening Dumbledore's
door see how many times you can say that
fast
Dumbledore's door at some point I would
like to get names and histories for all
these avatars we really only know about
a handful of them I know a lot of you
were wondering after the southern air
temple was destroyed and legend of korra
if there was a Hall of Avatar statues in
one of the other temples like air temple
island that that remains to be seen I do
think that there are our statues and
other temples just taking a step back I
feel like studio meters job animating
the southern air temple and Legend of
Korra did it much more justice than the
animation on Last Airbender obviously
it's a very different animation studio
so you can't compare quite as much and I
don't want to judge Last Airbender based
on Legend of Korra but if you want a
really trippy beautiful exploration of
that place just watch the book three
episodes moving along we meet Momo his
relationship with the winged lemurs is
actually a lot like the sky bison and
legend of korra mom was supposed to be
the only one to survive the genocide but
by the time we get to Korra meelo is
commanding an army of winged lemurs so
somewhere else in the world there's some
thriving colony I know a lot of people
were confused about the sky bison and
Korra where they all came from Brandon
Mike explained that this island here in
book two served as kind of a sanctuary
where they were bred in seclusion
during the hundred year war Anglo's his
and goes into the Avatar state when
he finds Scott so skeleton and it hits
him that he bailed when they needed him
the most is a nice emotional touchstone
for the character it's a big call to
action even though all that did not stop
him from still being a little kid after
recommitting himself to training and the
other elements like he's rededicated
himself to his purpose but he still
finds time to have fun and my number one
moment
Zuko versus Zhao in Agni Kai so they
don't take it as far as you think they
would because this is a Nickelodeon show
I mean it's for children but Agni Kai
always felt to me like it was meant to
be a duel to the death
Thunderdome rules to people enter one
person leaves the way they use it in the
series is much more like a non-lethal
fight of
but it still used as a stand-in for
trial by combat like when one character
challenges the word of another so if you
were say accused of something you could
probably Bluff your way into an Ag nakai
with your accuser and if you want you
might be allowed to walk away I guess
that would depend on the severity of
your crime Zucco defeating zhao is just
a nice reminder that even though he is
this castaway character he's still very
powerful very important it's also a
really good example of turning someone
who initially seemed like a really
simple villain into a much more
sympathetic antihero
despite the fact that he's still gunning
for aang he still has that murder you
look on his face here's my big question
for you guys
what did you like more in the episode
did you like the Southern Air temple
stuff or did you like Agni Kai better I
mean I feel like Agni Kai's where all
the action was but they definitely paid
off a lot of the lore from the southern
air temple in Legend of Korra
so just here's some cool
behind-the-scenes facts from the episode
so when the writers were first working
on mo Mo's character they thought about
presenting him as the reincarnation of
yatza the monk but they ultimately
decided against it mo Mo's name actually
derives from the Japanese term for peach
so after mo mo steals the fruit from
Sokka it's like Aang
names him based on the fruit then the
term Agni Kai is actually Bengali for
fire coral and combustion man's name
actually derives from his time in Agni
Kai fights like he was so good so quick
because of his ability that they named
him combustion man because he blew
fights up just overall the episode is
great I don't really have any
significant thumbs down it's just an
amazing example of a story that moves
the plot forward in a really big way
giving us a you know a really big
roadmap for the series like what's going
on with the Fire Nation
what Aang's going to be doing it
generates a ton of new lore for the
series via the southern air temple as
well as the Agni Kai stuff and it turns
a villain so go right here into an
antihero so the giveaway is continuing
it's at just a $20 Amazon gift card I
pick a random subscriber from the
comments all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment nice
and simple congratulations to this
week's winner young nation just message
me on my channel so I can get your
contact info thank you so I'm gonna try
and post my episode 4 video this weekend
be sure to subscribe to get it if you're
just finding me for the first time I've
also enabled fansubs with YouTube I'm
just I'm testing out a new feature for
them
so if you want you can submit subtitles
in your own native language on this
video there are details in the facepalm
video that posted so I'll add a link for
that in the description so while you
guys wait for more Avatar videos you can
click here for my facepalm video that I
posted it has the schedule for the rest
of this week as well as details on the
fansubs and you can click here for last
week's avatar video thank you so much
for watching so I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
[Music]